today I'll stick to football we continue
mocking the mock drafts and today I get
made fun of by Melo Akata for all my
mock draft stupidity we're also going to
talk to one of the best quarterbacks in
the 2020 NFL class that is Utah's jaylen
Johnson I'm excited for that you can
check all three of us out Matt Melo
Connor on Bleacher Report's the YouTube
page check out the stick to football
playlist you can also listen to this
podcast wherever you get your shows
whether that's iPhone Android however
you want to do it we're out there and we
appreciate you people still listen to
podcast I think more than ever actually
only 19 right watch him I have nothing
else to yeah and we're still cranking
out the YouTube shows so if you like
watching on YouTube your home now you
want to worry about your boss creeping
over your shoulder making sure you're
not doing your work so watch us on
YouTube and we'll be there for the
giraffe as well I know a lot of people
who are watching us on YouTube on their
TVs which I dan Kiefer sent me a photo
and he's like watching stick to a bonus
TV it's a great move I've started doing
that I have my TV set up so it's
compatible with my phone so I can
control YouTube on my TV from my phone
and if you haven't done that that's a
game one yeah I can't right now stood
son-of-a-gun
my mind gets blown to start the show
today uh that's um know what I'm doing
when I finally get home tonight all
right
as we say every show hopefully you guys
staying home staying safe and and we're
wishing the best for everyone listening
to this we definitely appreciate you
guys it is gonna be a fun show today I'm
excited to give you guys this mock draft
as we get into it but I wanted to start
the show here first of all and we're
recording this Tuesday morning happy
national beer day and so I wanted to ask
sometimes I put things that are
unscripted into the show what is your
favorite three beers because I know what
Melos gonna say so I added a couple in
there Kyle just like Connor go for his
blender boring Connors I'm Stockstill
your favorite beer yeah I'm stocked
white ales number one I would go with
anything from Kona at number two I like
the big waves but I've moved on to the
IPAs the kueh and the castaway and then
number three
and that's hard I don't know number
three stuff I really I really don't know
there's so many different choices I'm
glad you gave me three years difficulty
I not anymore it's too light I got away
from a lot of the lighter stuff and
graduated to IPAs
but once we without a winner yeah really
it's not for everyone
I'm such a I think they call it binge
drinker that I don't like how you know I
like I like the latter yeah you you
can't drink like six IPAs it doesn't
work like that really feel like absolute
dog [ __ ] the next day yeah so mellow
makes sense
natural light Bud Light and author ona
Dos Equis when I'm feeling fancy when
you're feeling a little some eating some
Mexican food right and you're feeling
fancy right yeah that's his fancy beer
my night guard wheat is number one I
think everyone probably knows that I
have a really hard time after that I
think allagash white is probably number
two and then I would say I'm stock is a
solid three DeLorean the the tremens
from delirium really good larium
delirium would be my third yeah I
haven't had one in a long time it
couldn't eat that allowed outside
anymore but when I was allowed outside
there are a couple bars in the West
Village that serve delirium and I've
been crushing like a lot of the blue
moon has a light beer now it's called
light sky and it's like so if you like
that kind of like citrusy taste but it's
only 95 calories and it's not real
filling which blue moons kind of heavy
so I've been drinking a lot of those cuz
it's been nice outside he may culture as
my skinny beer oh I drink Light beer and
that's about it I hate the taste of beer
I've tweeted that before I don't know if
I've ever said it on the show I think it
tastes disgusting like all of it but the
two at the top I can manage and I can
drink a lot of them I drink to drink kid
drunk that's the only reason I drink I'm
never just gonna sit down and weigh oh
let's have a casual beer because this
tastes really good that's not my style
that's me alright I didn't want to get
into this the NFL released the
all-decade team for 2010 to 2019 a lot
of it was expected but some
it was not and I know it's not always
fun reading a list on a podcast so you
can google it if you want I put it on my
Instagram as well Tom Brady the
unanimous choice at quarterback not
surprising there Adrian Peterson at
running back not a surprise for me there
Frank Gore making it as a running back
did surprise me and I'm a Frank Gore guy
the longevity that he's had is amazing
when I think of the four best running
backs from 2010 until 2019
I don't think of Frank Gore uh so I was
thinking that too and you know I'm not
the biggest Frank Gore supporter I don't
think he's a hall-of-famer but I don't
know who you've replaced him with on
this list you already have Marshawn
Lynch on there I think he earned his
spot LeSean McCoy is on there Frank Gore
might be ahead of him so I just don't
know from all Charles I know he was hurt
Sam but he still I believe still has the
records but Kerry Jamaal Charles should
be on there ahead of LeSean McCoy I
think what about Matt Forte that's
another good or is from 2010 to you know
really 2016 he was rushing for over 800
yards a year usually you know a thousand
but most importantly the guy was
catching a million passes right I think
he's the only thing the Bears had for a
long time you could put levy on bail in
there too oh yeah so some running backs
that are weird wide receiver really
can't argue a whole host this Antonio
Brown Larry Fitzgerald Calvin Johnson
Julio Jones any any problems there nope
just for me it would be Julio Jones did
he do it long enough in that era in that
decade he was drafted in 2009-10 right
spot and I I don't know I'm getting old
I think is I think that's what it is the
offensive tackles they hit Jason Peters
Tyrell Smith Joe Staley Joe Thomas I
would have liked obscene a right tackle
I think Mitchell Schwartz deserves to be
on this list in my opinion he's the best
right tackle on football and has been
for several years now maybe it's just
because he's dominated the second half
of the decade and these four left
tackles are really really good so am i
stupid for saying there should be a
right tackle on this list alright I
don't think you replace any of those
guys with one of the right tackles
though
so like I'm good with them having four
left tackles because I do think that
those are four of the best tackles in
the decade I mean I think Joe Staley
gets a little questionable for me but I
mean Joe Thomas tyrunt Smith Jason
Peters they were all very good for that
decade so I don't think Mitchell
Schwartz even as a Chiefs guy I don't
think the he replaces any of those guys
as a tackle I think the question would
be Lane Johnson
if there's anyone yeah 2013 draft yeah
hell of a player guards I don't know how
many people care about this other than
Jeff Schwartz but Jerry Evans Logan
Mankins Zack Martin and Marshall yonder
I got no problems with any of those guys
at sitter Alex Mack Marquis Pouncy it's
just good to see a Cleveland Brown on
this list defense so a couple surprises
I'm not gonna read the whole [ __ ]
list couple surprises Chandler Jones
made the list now he's been really good
for the last three seasons when I think
of the old decade team I don't think it
Chandler Jones and maybe that's my fault
maybe I'm just not thinking outside the
box enough on this Chandler Jones
surprised me I don't know I guess I had
him overrated I heard it I read his name
on probably your Instagram honestly it's
like yo yeah he's been solid for the
decade so I thought he deserved to be on
there yeah I like that he finally gets
recognition I feel like the guy never
does I agree that is true and what the
last three years he's had like eight dos
yeah you go check out stats he's not
that stats mean everything but like he
started in but his well and he's had
double-digit sacks every year except for
two years where he had six each I mean
led the league in 2017 with 17 sacks
last year had 19 yeah Chandler Jones
deserves to be on that the Patriots let
that guy go it's a sneaky bad move like
really bad move yeah really is because
they win Super Bowls so it doesn't you
know I mean right it's a sneaky you'd
like to have him would Jairus did
amateur quarterback like I mean since
they traded him 11 sacks 17 sacks 13
sacks 19 sacks van yeah and like a lot
of horse fumbles last year Jesus Christ
all right at lying back it's not like he
plays with superstars ever no definitely
not in Arizona not at all
I liked the linebackers Kuechly Khalil
Mack Vaughn
our Bobby Wagner Patrick Willis and
Jones was part of that crew as well
thought they did a good job on the D
ends and the D tackles the secondary I
know some people were a little upset but
I actually love this group they gave so
three corners three safeties to D B's is
how they did this Pat Pete Rivas and
Sherman at corner I don't think you can
argue with that
okay yeah I was nothing so I can't think
of one name that you'd go oh he should
be on there instead I cannot either at
safety Eric Berry and Earl Thomas came
out of the same draft class pretty cool
to see them had to save your spot in an
Eric Weddle who just hell of a player
and then DB Chris Harris jr. and Tyrande
Matthews I I thought they did a very
very good job the linebackers and the D
B's because those are the spots where I
think people pay more attention to the
stats and DBS are a little more well
known thought they really nailed it with
these guys I was actually surprised to
see Tyrone on there I feel like that
during his time in Arizona that he was
pretty underrated and was played very
well in the field he just never really
got a whole lot of recognition maybe
that's just because I really noticed him
last year and you almost forget about
the year he had with the Texans yep like
maybe Texans fans don't but as an NFL as
a whole we didn't really talk about the
honey badger that much that year no no
he just kind of got lost in the shuffle
down there which that's crazy a lot of
what he does is so underrated because
he's not getting he's not leading the
league in interceptions right he's just
doing a little bit of everything and
making a difference on the field yeah
I'm a huge honey badger fan and then
coaches Bill Belichick Pete Carroll they
didn't do general manager if I had to
pick a GM from the 2010s I would
actually take Ozzie Newsome I think that
the fact that they reinvented that team
a couple times during that era you know
from you know moving on from Ray Lewis
and edy Reed to building red Joe Flacco
and winning a Super Bowl to then
selecting a Lamar Jackson and setting up
what you know was the number one seed in
the AFC this past year I mean Aussie
would be my pick at general manager yeah
yeah I mean then you'd have to give
Belichick - you'd have to be the coach
and the GM and I think that's maybe why
they left him off yeah and we just
talked about how they traded Chandler
Jones so maybe we don't know I don't
think he's a good GM I think he's gonna
let the best coach of all time I do too
I don't think he's a good GM yeah
I think he gets credit for being the GM
but he's because he's so good as a coach
I think anybody could step in there and
be like all right but who should we take
it do a little bit better of a job I had
someone tell me once that Bella checked
the coach saves Bella check the GM's job
yeah oh for sure that's yeah totally
he should just hire me oh come on this
is what happens after Brady though like
I even as a Jared Stidham supporter
leading that fan club I wonder how much
success they're gonna have without Tom
Brady well I think it'll be a lot don't
get me wrong find out probably still be
a wild-card team but right I wonder how
much they'll do without time well let's
see what I do with this team with the
23rd pick in the NFL Draft we come back
I'm gonna run through my mock draft with
a couple trades in it ml O'Connor get to
discuss and grade this draft will be
back ready all right we are back in it
it's time for me to go through my mock
draft and let the boys make fun of it or
tear it apart or hopefully just say they
agree with all of it and yeah that'll be
fun yeah that'll be great man I love
everything thank you I appreciate it
okay number one overall Connor had it
sure Melo will have it this is not going
to change for most of us Joe borough
number one to the Cincinnati Bengals and
I've had borough as my top quarterback
since the Alabama LSU game I think in
the first quarter I looked at you guys
said you know what I'm gonna make
borough my number one quarterback I'm a
huge believer in him have him ranked as
the second best quarterback I've
evaluated only behind Andrew Luck I
think a lot of times we look at him and
say oh the supporting cast I don't think
his offensive line was that good having
seen him play in person I think four
times this past year his ability to
manipulate from within the pocket to
keep his eyes downfield to stay poised
to stay calm
he's not the athlete that my Holmes is
and he doesn't have the arm strength
that my Holmes has but some of the plays
he makes remind me of Aaron Rodgers
Patrick mahomes that ability to just go
off platform off schedule and just tear
the defense apart I really you look he
reminds we have none of those
quarterbacks not even a little bit
he doesn't have half the arm that I said
he doesn't have the arm I know but I do
like the way that he can keep plays
alive we were at the SEC championship
game and it's like what the hell is he
doing and he looks up and he throws a
bomb and I'm sitting there pretty high
up I didn't see Justin Jefferson somehow
heated with a bunch of Georgia Bulldogs
in his face so I do like that part of
his game but I think it's gonna be a
more boring quarterback then and Aaron
Rodgers and of Pat mahomes and those
guys are just there in their own tier
they're very exciting with what they can
do I think Joe burros gonna get the job
done I just don't think it'll be as
exciting yeah I'll stick with my Tony
Romo Matt Ryan blend which is definitely
a step down from the Rodgers moments
company again not the owner totally yeah
listen he's a good player he deserves to
go number one overall and I have no
gripes for this he's gonna be your next
treat Richard no oh my god if my only
worry about Joe borough has nothing to
do with him it has to do with the
Bengals I don't trust Zach Taylor and I
just haven't seen enough so am I worried
that Zach Taylor might ruin jobber oh
absolutely but I don't think he's gonna
be you know some spectacular JaMarcus
Russell Ryan Leaf type bus
I don't either I his floor he's better
than Jared Golf and he's gonna be a
starter in the league for five years out
of minimum okay there we go
people on Twitter think you hate Joe
borough I don't I just like to give you
[ __ ] about you okay number two the
Washington Redskins I have them going
chase young I do not think they even
consider to at this spot I don't think
they consider Justin Herbert at this
spot I mean there haven't doing Haskins
hosts their virtual draft coverage and I
know that last year the Cardinals were
oh well I'm a Josh josh is our guy josh
is our quarterback and then they draft
Kyler Murray this is a different
situation Washington takes chase Young
who is still by the way the best player
in the draft regardless of what you have
maybe heard elsewhere he is still the
best player in the draft he is a super
super talented pass rusher he is on par
with the BOCES he's on par with Miles
Garrett he's a poor word Jadeveon
Clowney and unlike a lot of those
players I just mentioned there are no
injury concerns would chase young like
there were those players coming out and
I think with the Redskins maybe they
were just putting some feelers out with
me what's gonna happen if we say we're
interested in the quarterback anybody
gonna try to come up and give us the
world for this pick and we'll move back
or anything like that but I don't think
they do
I think chase young is gonna be the pick
I think these first two picks we could
probably go ahead and
I don't see anything happening
differently and it feels like we never
get to talk about this pic anymore
because it's been set in stone for so
long but for Washington Redskins fans
and for the Ron Rivera era this is this
is underrated of how exciting it is
chase Young is a guy that should come in
and have double-digit sacks he is on par
with Miles Garrett he's that good I mean
it's almost like we nitpick because we
want to see him be a perfect run
defender but when it comes down to it
the guy gets after the quarterback
insane speed off the edge one of the
best first steps we have ever seen
so for Washington this is one of those
things where you send the card in right
away and it's so exciting for their
franchise and after San Francisco traded
to force Buckner I don't think it would
be crazy to say that Washington could
have the best D line of football next
year not at all oh yeah they have up
front Matt I&I just John Allen Doron
Payne Montes what Ryan Kerrigan and
chase young yeah that's good luck
Cowboys fans make you make your strength
a better a bigger strength that's what
you have to do if you are watching right
number three I did not do a trade out of
this and I'll explain why I have the
Detroit Lions selecting Jeff Okuda feel
very good about the need and the value
matching up here the reason I didn't
have a trade I started we did the mock
draft on Monday morning with Connors
mock and we're recording this about a
day later the more I thought about it I
don't know where the pressure will come
from for the Dolphins or the Chargers to
trade up to get their guy now maybe
there could but you don't have to what
you have to worry about is someone
jumping you it doesn't feel like either
team is getting that pressure that we've
seen before you know the Bears had to
trade up to number two to make sure they
got Travis key to make sure no one else
did it you know we've seen teams we saw
the Jets a couple years back they traded
up before the draft just like you know
what there will be a quarterback at
three that we like we're gonna train it
up and take one it does not right now
feel like there's that pressure for the
Dolphins or Chargers and as someone who
gets used by teams a lot I'll tell you
I'm not even hearing it of like hey
maybe you know I'm hearing that the
Chargers are gonna trade up to two or
three to get to or to get Justin Herbert
that talks not out there in fact what
you hear is almost the opposite of no
one can decide who the number two
quarterback is among teams so there's
maybe not going to be that panic move up
the board I don't think there is yet I
will
if there's draft night I think I said it
on our show Monday it's surprising that
the Chargers and the Dolphins are just
sitting there I picked five and six and
they haven't moved up yet so that does
tell me that maybe they do just want to
stay and nobody really wants to trade up
for to it you don't want to you know
have to send another first-round pick or
two second-round picks up to get a guy
that might be out of the league in three
years because of that injury when you
haven't had time to get him to meet with
your doctors and and do all the
behind-the-scenes stuff that it takes so
I wouldn't be surprised at all if the
Lions stay here or if you know come to
draft night if there is a trade I mean
I'm not gonna be surprised either way
I'm still convinced there's gonna be
some movement here now the question is
is there a mystery team behind them that
will put pressure on them I know we
allude to the Raiders a lot but it could
be much more than that
Jacksonville maybe if they want to come
up and grab a quarterback and surprise
everyone so when you look at it here I
mean it it's tough to dissect right now
because it's so Miami and chargers and
no one else so why would they move up
but come to wrap night I'm curious if
the pressure cranks up a little bit yeah
and if the Lions don't get that call
from Miami or from the Chargers would
they be willing to take a little bit of
a discount from someone you know from
one of those teams hey it's not a one
second rounder yeah it's not gonna be an
arm and a leg type deal it's just just
an arm all right number four the New
York Giants I'm still going with Isaiah
Simmons I believe in this pick I mean
there's a I would say there's like 90% I
feel on Simmons 10% Tristan works here
but I'm rolling with Isaiah Simmons as
what I think the pick will be again this
is not necessarily what we would do as
GM's but what I think will happen yeah I
think there's too much leaking out that
it's going to be Isaiah Simmons with the
new coaching staff they probably want to
playmaker on defense I don't know that
you get a better one
I mean honestly in a pretty normal class
I'm looking at chase young and Jeff
Okuda I say a Simmons the number three
defender on this list he's usually going
to be the number one guy we're just very
spoiled with these top three guys yeah I
think so as well when you look at it I
honestly I'm just gonna be vocal about
it it's not that Isaiah Simmons will be
a bad player he's far from that he's a
phenomenal player it's just such a tough
sell to me when you have Nate's older
and Cam Fleming as your tackles and
somebody like Jedrek wills or somebody
like Tristan works
is staring you right in the face there
when you just use the top five pick on a
running back a top ten pick on a
quarterback it just it's a tough it's
tough gme to me when you don't invest in
protecting those guys that's Dave
gentlemen for you you know yeah I agree
man it's like a lot of people think we
hate to Giants I don't I don't agree
with what Dave gentleman's doing or how
he's building that team but I have
nothing against oh no not a team in the
NFL I just don't like to move your team
makes yeah I'm with you on that all
right five the Miami Dolphins but all
the quarterbacks are here except for Joe
burrow so who did the Dolphins take and
I told Melo I did something this morning
and I obviously haven't got back enough
text yet to make informed opinion here
but what I did was I text everyone in my
phone who I think would know what the
Dolphins are doing a5 like no [ __ ]
no smoke screen who - the Dolphins want
to uh or Herbert or Jordan love I guess
you have to put that possibility in
there so I think this might be something
I have for you guys on the Friday show
but I am very curious to just cut
through the fat hey who do they want not
are we being manipulated right now as of
April 7th at 10 a.m. Central Time I
believe the pic will be Justin Harbor
over to us this is not what I would do I
have her Buress I mean he's way down the
list I told you guys on Monday we're
doing draft 400 we're still stacking the
board Toa is far and away like 30 spots
better on my big board probably than
Justin Herbert the only questions I have
a to are health-related
so I have Miami a five going Herbert and
then the Chargers at six going to a
which I do think is a great fit for tua
but I will always struggle with the idea
that Herbert went above to it in this
year's draft I and I think that teams
will once they look back at it but I I
think this is another thing obviously
you're hearing that it could happen
we've been talking about it on the show
I don't agree with it could it be a
possibility yeah especially the more the
Dolphins just stay there at number five
tells me they're okay with taking either
one of these quarterbacks and they
haven't done the medical so maybe you
take the safer option in Justin Herbert
and you don't have to worry about a
quarterback like - and that hip and
those ankles and every other injury that
he's had in his career or maybe the
Dolphins just played this perfectly and
they're gonna make it so they didn't
have to move up
give up any of their assets and they go
hey - is there a five we'll take them
now so I'm very curious as well I've
leaned on the side that they like Justin
Herbert health reasons being one maybe
size reasons being another one I think
when you look at Miami I'm curious how
they build this thing guys I was doing a
little exercise just researching all the
GM's and you know Chris Grier has really
only had oversee you know overseeing
football operations there for about a
year now and Chris careers been there
since 2007 so we're wondering what moves
were his well it was warrant but now
that he's working with the coach that he
hired in Brian Flores these are gonna be
what the real Chris Grier moves are
going forward yeah and it's I know
everyone's like what would New England
do it's not that some it's not no it's
not yeah definitely not I know they you
know maybe on defense they brought in
some guys that Flores is familiar with
but I don't think it's as simple as what
would build with New England they had 20
years of a quarterback where they didn't
have to worry about it
where they did very minimal work on
quarterback so it's completely different
for these teams all right now let's have
some fun
number seven overall the Carolina
Panthers own this pick oh but we're
trading baby the New York Jets are
coming up the board I looked back at
last year's trade when the Steelers
moved up to ten
they sent a 1 a 2 and a future 3 to do
that so I'm going to send the Jets are
moving up they're giving the Panthers
pick 11 pick 79 and a 2021 third-round
pick and the reason being you're not
going up as high and in this year's
draft
I think the Panthers are definitely
listening about moving back so that the
cost is not going to be as great
especially in a kind of a weird draft
year so the Jets move up it cost them a
one and two threes they have the picks
to do that they have two third-round
picks in 2020 and they can find a comp
pick 2021 to make this happen so I have
the Jets taking the top tackle in class
two Jedrek wills from Alabama the more I
thought about the lack of moves they've
made in free agency it makes me wonder
if Joe Douglas is willing to get
aggressive any year where they have a
little extra draft capital to get a sure
thing at left tackle and the only thing
that I would say who was the pick wills
Wilson I wouldn't be surprised if the
Panthers
stay there and take a tackle and not
move off of this I think that is the
strong possibility after they trade I
know we made fun of Russell Oh cooing
and he's always hurt they've traded for
Oh [ __ ] they have moat net right tackle
I have no idea what they're gonna do a
Greg little who they drafted in the
second round 2018 but they have a couple
guys there at least yeah I I mean if
they do it cool I just don't know if
it's the Panthers I think maybe the
Cardinals are a better trade option for
the Jets if they do want to move up but
they have the picks to do it and they
really need a left tackle so maybe the
are a team that is trying to get up
there and get a guy like worse or wills
I'll say Matt I love this trade because
you keep pick 48 and you keep pick 68
which they got from the Giants so it
doesn't feel like you don't have any
draft capital in this draft with all the
Jets needs right now and you go up and
get what I consider a surefire franchise
tackle for Sam Donald so I love this
move I don't want to sit at 11 because
I'm not convinced that you know wharfs
andrew thomas and all these players will
be there but more importantly i valued
Jedrek wills way higher than all of them
so I think this is a phenomenal trade by
getting your guy but not really
surrendering your draft to do so yeah
and I wanted to find a couple more
trades like that in this draft but it
was hard to do right this early in the
process so I ate I still have the
Cardinals taking Derek Brown feel very
very good about the Intel on that one
yeah I do too I think that's gonna be
the pig all right number nine the
Jacksonville Jaguars are on the board
and this is where I'm gonna have a
couple tackles come off the board so at
nine I have Jacksonville taking Tristan
works.you move cam Robinson inside to
guard
I think this offensive line is a hell of
a lot better when cam Robinson's playing
guard
Juwan Taylor right tackle Tristan wharfs
at left tackle you got yourself a line
that you can build around now no matter
who they're gonna play a quarterback
whether it's Minshew or someone they
draft I think you have to have an
identity on offense and this helps you
get one with a very very tough offensive
line and then at ten I have the Browns
taking Makai Becton from Louisville so
we get two tackles coming off the board
the Browns I think would consider Isaiah
Simmons if he somehow fell to this spot
says he's off the board I think they
have to go with bekhten I would love to
see the Browns get I say a Simmons just
because I want to see him
first Lamar Jackson and I'm not gonna
get to see that very often
and with him on the Giants maybe that's
why I hate the Giants so much but I I
think we are gonna see a run on tackles
especially here with the way your Mach
is working out you have the Jets moving
up and I think these other teams are
gonna say okay let's start doing it
the Jaguars sitting there can get
Tristan whoops I really like that move I
like worse I think he can play all along
that offensive line and then the Browns
with Becton they have to do something to
tackle I don't know if it'll be him or
Thomas but I think the upside here is
what Beck 10 gets why Becton gets
drafted at number 10 yeah I'm a big fan
of this pick at nine for Jacksonville
because once again you can get help at a
couple positions whether you need works
to plug in and play guard he could do it
whether you need them playing the right
or left side he can do it so I'm a big
fan of the value at nine and the need 10
with the Browns this pick would not
surprise me I could see them taking
backed in and saying hey we're gonna
shoot for the stars for this pick rather
than getting the high floor guy in
Andrew Thomas because they probably feel
pretty good
after signing Jack Conklin for the right
side where they feel they could be a
little bit more you know bold here on
the left side with Becton and most
importantly - they're gonna run the ball
a lot with Nick Chubb and we know what
Becton can do as a run blocker that was
actually what went into that thought
process for me of bekhten
over Thomas's they have not only Nick
Chubb left cream hunt they want to run
the ball next year and Becton will help
Andy Janovich like they are just
building a hey we got ourselves the
full-back we got ourselves two running
backs they just look like a team that
wants to run the ball million times a
game we're good way to protect the
quarterback who did not have a good year
last year in Baker Mayfield all right 11
the Panthers slide back here because the
trade with the Jets and I think this
works out perfectly for them because
this is where you take CJ Henderson at
corner a gigantic need for them after
James Bradbury went to the Giants a lot
of folks have said like why not
offensive line
why not defensive tackle you could go
either one of those spots and I'm
probably not gonna get too upset about
it but I do think like we said after
training for Russell o Kuhn you got a
couple young guys I don't think you take
a guard in this spot to replace Trey
Turner instead you get in my opinion the
second best corner in the draft someone
who's ready to come in and play right
away
Matt roll Joe
rady we think oh man they're gonna go
offense good offensive coordinators know
how valuable a shutdown corner is and I
think Henderson can be one I I think so
too I think that he's not on the same
tier as a CUDA because the CUDA is
special but man he's right there
and I think he's on a tear of his own
because I think he's head and shoulders
above a guy like Jeff Gladney in some of
these other corners obviously I really
like CJ Henderson and you got to do
something to slow down you have to look
at your division and say how do we win
that first and you better be able to
stop the past because you have the
Saints you have the Bucks and you have
the Falcons who probably have some of
the best receivers in all of football
not even just in their division that's
gonna be tough to stop and you have to
try with a guy like CJ Henderson yeah I
don't mind this pic at all I think it
might be it might seem a little early
for CJ Henderson here for the Panthers
this is a need once again I'm not a big
believer in their tackle situations so I
might be inclined to take Andrew Thomas
here instead but they are really
building this thing you know from the
bottom here with Matt rule and they know
they need more pieces in that secondary
and Henderson is one of the best ones
available on the board all right number
12 the Raiders I'm going to see D lamb
here something I've been hearing a lot
the last week is that lamb is the number
one receiver on the Raiders board if
he's available I personally would take
Henry rugs here like rugs would be my
pick because I value speed so much for
their offense but I think when you look
at lamb what he does at the catch point
how physical he is a route runner I
think that fits mike Mayock
so well of let me just get a dog at wide
receiver I've said before I think CD
lamb in the right offense can be a
Michael Thomas type player even though
he's 25 pounds lighter just the
physicality that he runs the routes with
like this is Derek Carr's best friend
now you got a couple really good tight
ends well one really good tight end one
really old when you had Aaron Waller and
Jason Witten and they have some other
pieces at receiver Hunter Renfro guys
like that
I think lamb is plug and play here is
your X receiver and a day one impact and
I think he's gonna be the number one
receiver on a lot of boards I don't know
how many teams are gonna value Henry
rugs and what he does with the speed but
I think for the Raiders here go give
Derek Carr a target you need a receiver
you thought you had one in Antonio Brown
we also have that that were
toute I really like Siddhi Liam number
two receiver for me in this class but I
still like this pic here with him 12
overall to the Raiders even with Jerry
Judy on the board best receiver in the
draft first one to come off the board
this is a great pick by the Raiders I
understand the need for speed with rugs
but with CD lamb you are helping the
quarterback you have right now and any
quarterback that place in the future I
think lamb does everything very well
underneath but can you know quietly be a
down field threat as well with his
tracking and ability to play above the
rim now to the picks I actually care
about 13 the San Francisco 49ers so that
was a joke for people who don't know 13
the Niners they get this pick from Indy
for DeForest Buckner and it's gonna be a
wide receiver it's not Jerry Judy it is
Henry rugs Kyle Shanahan once speed
here's some four to nine speed for you
Henry rug stretch in the field I was
thinking about this that last night and
this morning as I was doing this mock
draft Kyle loves speed loves it I mean
the thing about guys who've been
marketed would he make Taylor Gabriel
look like a Pro Bowler now you give him
speed at receiver who's actually a well
rounded wide receiver
I think rugs would be I mean they drove
to Dante Pettis in the second round
which was a horrible miscalculation
you're getting like the souped-up good
version of that now at 13 overall yeah I
think it makes sense I mean just look at
their running backs and all the speed
that they have there they're the second
fastest team in the NFL so now you have
debo Samuel and you put Henry rugs on
there as well it's gonna be scary I hope
Jimmy Garoppolo doesn't overthrow Henry
rugs that would be impressive it's hard
to do it's over throwing rugs here
listen it's crazy guys that we're
sitting here in Jerry Judy's is gonna be
the third receiver off the board I would
think unless Matt surprises us but
that's just the kind of rise that lamb
and rugs have had together and I like to
fit in both of these offenses to be
honest with you I think the Niners can
get rugs going down the field early and
often
all right 14 the Tampa Bay Buccaneers
you get Tom Brady now you have to
protect him
I'm gonna go Andrew Thomas who I think
could play left or right tackle in the
NFL and do either spot really well so if
Tampa believes more in their left tackle
situation than I do
so okay put him on the right side he has
experienced there he can get the job
done but protecting Tom Brady has to be
first and foremost
on Jason lights list of things to doing
this year strap it help out your run
game I think that he's one of the best
run blockers in this draft even ahead of
a guy like Becton I think that Thomas
moves a lot better he's gonna be able to
get to the second level he's gonna be
able to do more immediately I think
Becton maybe in year 3 is gonna be a
better run blocker but for right now
andrew thomas is best run blocker in
this class yeah get you a man that could
do both guys andrew thomas left tackle
right tackle run blocker past protector
it's you know it's crazy how often he is
the fourth tackle off the board for how
reliable this player is but you know up
side I understand why Pete why teams
chase it but I just love how rock-solid
Andrew Thomas of a prospect is all right
16 the Atlanta Falcons last pick before
we - Oh 15 excuse me Denver Broncos
sorry didn't work try to skip you here
and you get my favorite receiver in the
draft so I shouldn't have done that
Jerry Judy comes off the board here I
think he's a perfect complement to
Courtland Sutton you got two fantastic
route runners now I would not be shocked
if Judy's picked seven by the Panthers
if they don't trade I would not be
shouting three Falls to 15 because in
this receiver class it is so much gonna
come down to scheme fit and preference
what do you want from that position and
what do you already have like what do
you need you know the Niners have Deebo
Samuel whose great crossing I was great
over the middle would they value a CD
lamb and with a value a jerry judy or
they want deep speed I think with Denver
they would be so happy to begin to
imagine you're Drew lock and you now
have Courtland Sutton Melvin Gordon Noah
fan and now you have Jerry Judy like
that's how you build an offense oh I
totally agree I think they could go
tackle here if there's one available in
your draft there's not so I think with
Jerry Judy sitting there this is a
no-brainer this is okay we need a
receiver the number one receiver on our
board is there let's go get him now what
a steal for the Broncos here and I would
have been happy with lamb rugs or Judy
for them but I think you're talking
about maybe the most Pro ready of the
three wide receivers with Judy just
because of his route running ability and
a cross from Courtland Sutton that is a
really nasty one-two punch
number five overall player on my board
somehow falls to 15 good for drew lock
in those Broncos no joke number 16 now
we're ready for the Falcons and I have
them go Javon Kinlaw we see Jay
Henderson off the board no corner I felt
great about drafting here for this team
specifically so I'm gonna give them
Javon Kinlaw a top-10 player who slides
down the board because that run on
tackles and wide receivers and I think
this is the mold of what they want from
their interior defensive linemen I don't
know is there a spot for him immediately
though with a guy like greedy jarred
already there I think he plays next lady
and then he can kick out play some end
as well I'm not a Tyler Davidson guy I
know I think they extended him but I
think he and Grady Jarrett that's a
pretty deadly duo and you can pressure
from the inside you got a guy like Dante
Fowler you picked him up on free agency
so helped free up the the money you just
spent yeah Dan Quinn is gonna value you
know a front like this guys that are
just pass rushers Kinlaw athletic Grady
Jared athletic Dante Fowler athletic mad
you have Kinlaw ahead of chase on I do
not do you think they would play don't
for chase on it could go either way
AB but I think would tack McKinley and
then with Dante Fowler you're not going
to have to chase on us Lauren gotcha all
right let's take a break we come back
Cowboys on the clock the Dallas Cowboys
are on the clock at 17 this is where I
have Kayla Vaughn chase on coming off
the board the value is just too good to
pass up
I don't think edge rushers the biggest
need here not a corner I would draft for
Dallas not addy tackle I would drive for
them so chase on my number nine overall
player Falls to 17 yeah I still think
it's a sneaking need Aldon Smith hasn't
played football in a very long time very
true
Dexter Lorenz how long is he gonna be
there how long is it gonna be productive
I think you can play him opposite of
those guys or even rotate him in and
make Alden Smith you're just third down
bring him into the rest of the
quarterback I think Chase sign can be a
more complete edge player in this
defense and you better do something
because that defensive line needs some
help yeah it's a great pick Matt I mean
he's somebody that could do you know
pretty much all three things you ask a
linebacker get after the quarterback
cover and play really really reliable
run defense super high character guy
which I think you want more of in that
Dallas locker right so I mean you know
him out and Smith there it's an
interesting one too and hopefully all
seriousness hopefully out in Smith has
his life back on track but chase on it's
a great pick for Dallas 18 the Miami
Dolphins no surprise here we've had them
going offensive tackle at 18 for
months now maybe the only surprise I'm
gonna give them Austin Jackson from USC
and then here's the surprise pic for you
though and you guys could talk about
both these 19 the Raiders have this pick
they went wide receiver at 12 I have
them going Trayvon Diggs from Alabama
trying to tap in to more of that mike
Mayock philosophy of tough high
character guys from big programs who
were productive in college Diggs has a
lot of speed at the corner spot as well
he's got a lot of the traits that you're
gonna look for if you're the Raiders I I
wouldn't be surprised if he's the corner
three I would take Gladney over Diggs
but the upside with Diggs is so good
because if he can learn how to play
corner and use those feet he has elite
level feet I really like Diggs I don't
know about 19 19 might be a little rich
for me yeah I think with Diggs he will
go higher than Gladney because of the
size I think that's where he'll win that
battle there and it'll be interesting to
see how teams value Diggs verse fault in
first jaylen Johnson who were gonna have
on in a little bit and getting back to
your pick at 18 Matt with the dolphins
I've heard so much buzz on Austin
Jackson for two to three months now
where this wouldn't shock me I'm just
gonna be honest and kind of take the
Justin Herbert route here that we do on
this show I don't think Austin Jackson
is a round one player and whatever team
takes him in the top 25 I think is
making a big mistake if they're
expecting results this year or really
the next year and a half at 25
Jacksonville they took an offensive
tackle earlier I'm giving them a wide
receiver here in Justin Jefferson from
LSU and I'll follow that up we often
have the Eagles take Justin Jefferson
he's not available but they're still
gonna go to Baton Rouge to get Patrick
Queen giving them a speedy playmaker at
linebacker which is a very very big need
for that defense yeah I think that makes
sense because it never really works out
that way you wanted to when you have
justin jefferson fall into 21 somebody
else usually steps up and takes that
player i like justin jefferson to the
jaguars i think that him and DJ shark
are gonna be scary duo in a couple years
once they have a quarterback patrick
queen with the eagles I think Eagles
fans will be a little upset they're not
getting in that receiver they want but I
wouldn't reach for a guy like a t
Higgins right here at this spot I know
how he Roseman in this Eagles front
office they haven't invested like a
premium asset into the linebacker
position it feels like ever
I think Jordan Hicks in the third round
like half a decade ago is the last time
they came even close but I think this is
a good idea Patrick Queens not just a
linebacker he's one of the best cover
players in this entire draft and and he
would make an impact right away and most
importantly it's because the Jaguars
stole JEP just in Jefferson at 20 who I
think is just perfect what Gardner
Minshew in that offense right away I
mean him DJ charkh another LSU guy they
got some speed they got a possession guy
that's a really really nice blend of
wide receivers together yeah I had
thought about going corner there for
Jacksonville but having Jefferson on the
board it was just too tempting to get
home you're a young quarterback right
that's that was exactly where I want to
go so they got a tackle on a receiver in
this trap 22 the Vikings got this pick
from Buffalo for Stefon Diggs I'm gonna
corner for the Vikings before wide
receiver and that's AJ Terrell from
Clemson you mentioned jaylen Johnson
Christian full and Jeff gladden you're
on the board
I think the Vikings are gonna want some
size at the position which might rule
out Gladney but also I mean they're
still gonna what speed and I like trill
I know everyone's lasting impression is
Jamar chase beating him in the second
half of the nati the first half he was
keeping up with him he was holding his
own he used his length exceptionally
well
swatting balls away I think Terrell has
all the tools you want maybe he's not
gonna be you know today Vyas white you
know late first round who becomes an
all-pro corner but I think you be a
really good starter or maybe he is going
to be white because I mean there's a
lead level tape of him out there
shutting down guys he has the length and
I think that is what puts him ahead of a
guy like Gladney here again with Diggs
but I I like this pick I think they're
gonna have to take a corner first no
receivers there that I like right now
Higgins just the 4 or 5 was scaring me I
need to go back and watch a little bit
more tape and remind myself of how good
of a receiver he is hey listen guys when
you're a 6 1 corner with 4 for speed and
the kind of tape Terrell has once again
let's not just you know cherry-pick a
play against Jamar chasey or the overall
tape
I think Terrell is gonna be a sneaky
first-round pick for a lot of people
right now yeah I'm a big fan I almost
had him go to Oakland at 19 that's how
much I like AJ to roll all right 20 they
like their Clemson cones they do like
yeah Trayvon Mullen and AJ Chow let's
get it back together it worked pretty
well in college number 23
with Patriots not a quarterback even
though Jordan loves on the board I gave
them you tour gross motto is think we
talked about Chandler Jones earlier in
the show Trey flowers think the pass
rushers this team has drafted and then
let leave I think they have to get back
to those roots of getting after the
quarterback Chris mottos little bit more
of a potential over-production player
but I really really like the flashes
from him I have him comped to Chandler
Jones alrighty thank you there you go
it's a fit all right I mean when you
look at gross Matos it's just an athlete
they lose Kyle van Noy
and I know gross Matos is gonna project
as a pass rusher but I think bill would
use him in a lot of different ways yeah
he is a fun place you know he's just raw
so filling him out as a prospect I think
he'd be very very good 24 the Saints
still not a quarterback
I'll go kenneth murray here the team
only has five picks in the 2020 draft
they have a super bowl window that is
open i think they're gonna try to win
now and then maybe re-evaluate the
quarterback position next year 2021 so
Kenneth Murray here we've talked about
the character the athleticism they need
a linebacker who can not only stop the
run but get outside the hashes and make
some plays I think Murray can do that
and I don't know if they value a
quarterback in the first round just yet
I mean if they do I think it might be
Taysom Hill who they gave a first-round
tender to I'm not buying that but I also
I don't think the Saints will take a
quarterback in the first round yeah it's
funny they get Murray I think he'd be
joining a guy that is very similar to
him into Mario Davis but tomorrow Davis
will be a free agent after this year and
it's getting a little up there in age so
they do need help at linebacker and
watching those two play together for a
year would be really exciting Melo you
mentioned this guy earlier 25 of the
Vikings I gave him a corner now they get
T Higgins I think this is the strategy
whether it's Higgins or Brandon I hear
or I mentioned it the other day Jalen
Rieger could be a surprise pick for them
I think the move is to grab a corner
wait on a receiver
I still like T Higgins I know like you
said the four five six the protein might
scare some folks the route running what
he does vertically it's gonna be a
really good match with Adam Thielen and
the other pieces they have that wide
receiver puzzle but most importantly I
think he gets safeties out of the box
for down and cook which is something
that I would prioritize for this offense
and a real good red zone target like you
can't underestimate that he can't go up
and get the football
and I think that he can't separate the
40 time is just concerning it is it
definitely is a concern and I like what
he does after the catch - it's like he
has to get the ball in his hands to get
a little momentum but once again a
player with a huge catch radius that can
hit you just gave Kirk Cousins all that
money again part two Frank you you can't
just get rid of stuff on digs and expect
him to be the same Kirk Cousins so you
need a player to supplement Adam Thielen
yeah all right 26 the Dolphins we had
them to a quarterback tackle earlier I'm
Adam Dondre Swift I know Dolphins fans
are tired of this they hate me for it
I'm gonna keep doing it until they
Jordan Howard's not the answer at
running back fellas he might be part of
the answer but he's not the answer I
think Jordan how are you John tricks we
have complemented each other very very
well
this gives Swift an opportunity to
acclimate to the NFL but by the second
half of the season he's your number one
back I think this is a best pick for the
Dolphins I've heard in a long time I
think you have to make a splash move
like this I don't think Jordan Howard's
the answer either but I think he's a guy
that can help carry the load with
DeAndre Swift at least for those first
couple weeks was for six weeks of the
season and then we'll see a guy like
DeAndre swift absolutely take over that
spot I hated their draft up until this
with Justin Herman Austin Jackson but I
loved DeAndre swift I think he's a top
15 player in this class I think from
Miami that gives them an identity on
offense along with Devante Parker and
you know for all the hate on Herbert
Herbert swift you start to rebuild this
line this might be a team that can run
the football very very well and keeping
the offensive tackle talk going 27
either Seahawk Sydney Josh Jones they've
lost a lot of dudes on the offensive
line over the years they could always
upgrade here and then a surprise pick 28
to Baltimore Ravens we've all you know
AJ epinet could be a pick here I'm gonna
go linebacker
I think Zack bond fits very very well
what they want defensively they want
chess pieces
Zack Vaughn can be that we saw him as a
pass rusher at Wisconsin then we saw him
play off ball linebacker at the Senior
Bowl
I think bond is a little bit of a Swiss
Army knife what you want him in the hand
of the dirt and third down he'll go get
the quarterback but as we've said before
this is a team that's gonna play with
the lead a lot you got to have people
who can't stop the pass and Zack bond
could do that whether he's rushing or
playing a coverage yeah somebody on
Twitter
paired him one of our listeners to Clay
Matthews and now I can't unsee it I
think he's a little bit of a guy that
can do everything and if you want him to
rush off the edge you can if you want to
blitz from middle linebacker do it he's
just not big enough to fit that true
edge rusher mold but he's got the tools
to do it and getting back to the Seattle
pick I know they signed Brandon shell in
free agency but that's not gonna solve
all your past protection woes I'll uh
trust me take it from me I've watched
every snap of his career 27 with the
Seahawks Josh Jones that's a really
really nice pick I'm actually surprised
Jones Falls that far he's been one of
the more reliable pass protectors in the
country the last couple seasons here and
for Seattle to have Dwayne brown on one
side I'm curious if you can kick Jones
over to the right side I think so I
think we saw at the Senior Bowl he has
the power to do that twenty-nine the
Titans I have them get in a corner in
Jeff Gladney and then 30 the Packers not
Denzel Mims which might surprise you
guys
I have Brandon I you going here the more
hot like I've been going back and
watching guys trying to finish up draft
400 notes I have really liked Brandon I
you can the only thing that worries me
is like the injury we didn't see me the
Senior Bowl gives him at the combine as
long as he's good to go for whenever the
season starts Brandon Oak is the first
round receiver what he does with the
ball in his hands is so so special I
mean there's some way I know I've said
before like it's Sammy Watkins in
college there's some like Odell Beckham
an NFL type movements from him with the
ball in his hands
not as a route runner almost explosion
as big of a fan on IU cuz everybody else
is I see him as a second-round guy I
would rather have a big target like a
Denzel mems here to play across from
Davante Adams I guess you're going speed
here with IU but I guess in the first
round I'd rather have Mims yeah me too
well starting with the Gladney pick gets
a great pick for Tennessee load up on
the secondary you know even if you want
to kick a Dori Jackson inside play
Gladney on the outside they're
interchangeable
I think Bryant yeah I'm with you he's a
second-round guy I would not be I
wouldn't be overly excited maybe it's a
good fit for the Packers
that's what I was thinking yeah right
but he's just very raw in the injuries I
would be man it would be tough to pass
on Mitch I actually have a couple
receivers ahead of him in this class on
the
but like you said Matt they went round
one cuz of it that his athleticism and
ability to create I wouldn't be shocked
right thirty-one I have a trade up the
forty niners trade back from this spot
the Indianapolis Colts give them 34 and
75 to move up and get Jordan Love who
somehow spelled out more of time for
some love I have said it a billion times
the Colts don't have a quarterback under
contract for next season
now they do and this might even open the
door to a Jacoby Brissette trade I would
not be shocked if we see that happen
draft weekend so the Colts have Jordan
love to learn behind Phillip Rivers for
a year who maybe they can get a second
round pick back for a guy like
percentage because some teams might
panic for a quarterback I wonder about
this trade though if they loved him so
much why not take him in the teens and
not 31 overall well they they traded the
third I know oh you said white Rayford
so why do I move off that spot with
49ers this is more like an opportunity
you see you see it something happening
in you so you know following any Jeff on
it you'll get the fits very Drew Lockean
the Broncos last year a little earlier
yeah little earlier it would be a hammer
getting Jacob Eason still you know it's
like well he fell all the way here so we
might as well give this a whirl it's
like the date that you really didn't
want to go on but you're like yeah I got
really nothing to do and you know we'll
see how it goes first day after
quarantine right all right Melo's
tenders gonna be unstoppable that first
after quarantine all right 32 Melos team
the Kansas City Chiefs I actually looked
for a trade out scenario here and
couldn't find one so instead I've given
him my guy Clyde the glide Edwards it'll
air from LSU running backs right oh
shoot me off I am trying to make you mad
today nice little Tuesday morning and
then you have to do something like this
with Jonathan Taylor on the board [ __ ] I
would take Susan Ruiz ten out of ten
times here
I mean build the line I Pat mahomes
doesn't need one of these running backs
I'm sorry you can find a guy in the
fifth or fourth the fifth or sixth round
that'll that'll do just as well I'm just
I'm trying to channel my inner Brett
Veatch what would Brett do receivers not
there but I would I would rather see
interior offensive line yeah I could say
KJ Hamill they haven't shot offensive
line I mean like two of their starters
need to your offensive line or Street
agents yes they don't value it oh I know
yeah well my home's got hurt last year
though and that wasn't their fault
though I mean that like that was a fluke
play he's running for his life a lot he
it I'd rather him not running for I do
think having argued with him about that
some of that's just him like that's
that's his strategy for getting guys
open but if they went Ruiz here I would
be I would be ecstatic for Pat because I
do think he gets hit too much but just
what I'm hearing everything points to
running back I hope that's not the one
all right well it might be this guy
who's coming up next jaylen Johnson
corner from Utah thanks for hanging with
us Jalen we're looking forward to
talking to him one of the toughest
corners in this year's class we'll be
right back with the you ready for this
all right guys we are joined today by
jaylen Johnson from Utah one of my
favorite corners in the class a player I
know we all believe could be a
first-round selections - Jalen I got a
nap first of all thank you for coming on
we know it's like an unprecedented draft
process so thank you for your time but I
want to ask as a player who waited to
have surgery on your labrum until after
the combine have you been able to get
that done in a world where like a lot of
elective surgeries aren't happening
hospitals are little crowded have you
been able to get that injury cleaned up
started all stuff like that's on me
right now I'm a rehab from home that's
why the only thing that's slightly
hindered right now can really go to a
rehab facility with the process and with
the exercise that I need to do what went
into your decision to go ahead and work
out before having surgery I'm just
trying to get myself every event I can
get knew I was going to do the
interviews pretty well I just wanted to
really showcase on the field as much as
I can do and just try to show off unless
in my
physical work as well my mental work
Jill and I've read that you graduated in
two and a half years at Utah before
leaving as an underclassman for the NFL
Draft which is insanely impressive how
hard was it
balancing school and football and I've
read that you also had great grades as
well just what was that like during your
time at Utah oh just about prioritizing
this it was some long nights and stuff
like that I mean it was just other
commitment that I made to myself and
just made to the whole process when I
first came into college because that was
my goal from the very beginning to give
myself an opportunity to go to the NFL
leave college without my degree I mean
it was just a lot of sacrifice going
into it and just kind of maintaining and
sticking to what some rough patches in
there seeing all my friends go out and
see my not having study study time and
all just different stuff like that I was
always kind of uncomfortable but I mean
at the day I had a different vision and
a lot of people did and have different
goals I mean it was just really staying
true to myself and stay true to what I
wanted to do graduating a two and a half
years I mean it says a lot about your
work ethic your dedication
what's your post football plan because
your likes you out you have to have a
plan most guys aren't going and playing
powerful football and it's starting at
corner and graduating in two and a half
years that's that's pretty unique based
on what I can do an inner fill and the
platform I can build but I mean honestly
for myself I just want to be able to
empower just being able to help out in
sports not just football but just in
sports in general and then in life in
general I mean there was so much that I
didn't know myself the young man in high
school middle school I felt like was so
important to me in my adulthood in terms
of the life that I'm going to go into
and then I even went through
I mean I just want to be able to give
that knowledge back down to the younger
generation just kind I mean I didn't
really have too much knowledge of what
taxes were what LLC was when certain
things like that was I mean just being
able to give that knowledge back to
other people couldn't just know how to
start a credit card what is credit
score's I mean now everybody start a
credit card you want a statistician once
I was that and I really don't and I
didn't know too much about it so I had
to go and learn about it now and I feel
like that's something that he's central
for kids in high school to know kids
start to learn about and how the economy
is ran and white gas prices go up and
down I mean that certain things that
people take for granted but it is going
to be central or the important later on
in life I mean I just want to be able to
help build kids on the on their in their
sport and off the field as well well I
don't I don't know about high school
kids you're younger than me but maybe I
could be your first student there and
you can teach me some of this stuff too
so what are you doing right now to stay
in shape with everything that's going on
in the world I know you're rehabbing the
shoulder but what else are you doing to
kind of keep yourself active I think
working out working out again I mean I
couldn't really move too much the squats
and air squats trying to get back
acclimated and moving and getting my
legs back under me getting my weight in
my wind back so when I can't start
really running and moving I'm not going
to be too far out of shape but I'm just
doing rehab they're trying to get back
acclimated into physical exercise I
remember you being a highly touted
recruit you know one of the better
cornerback prospects in your class
especially army all-american how'd you
end up at Utah I mean I know Utah has
been a great football program you know
the last couple years here but how did
you end up going there honestly again
and just went back to making a business
decision just know I wanted in a school
now really when I know my visit I really
went to Utah
because Winningham and all the coaches
with a list of things that I was looking
for in the school and they really were
able to check off thing every boxer did
check off every box in terms of getting
exposure in terms of having the chance
to play early my freshman year being
able to get a good quality degree being
able to learn and around good coaches
and being around good people I mean it
was just just about more what I wanted
in school and they were able to give me
everything I wanted no Jalen well you
know a big part of my job is be our lead
draft guys to write you know positives
and negatives about a player players
they usually like the negative side but
what's one of the the worst critiques
you've heard about yourself like not
worst is in like some you need to fix
but just the most wrong analysis you've
heard about yourself as a player you
ever see some my Twitter where
somebody's like trashing your game you
like what that does even make sense I
would probably say when people say my
versatility and coverage like oh he's
just a zone just his own guy or oh he
owns something and and I feel like I've
displayed both of me being that I
followed around the number one receiver
all year on in each game so I mean I
don't see where somebody can say I'm all
yours own guy when I was locking up
receivers week after week so I mean I
was one thing and then another thing I
kind of seeing was somebody saying I had
like stiff hips that was one that was
talking to me being that my training
goes into having a loose system being
able to open and being able to brake
very effectively very efficiently so I
mean I don't see where I made please me
where I had tightness there and I may
play with my hips of being able to open
and break I mean I don't I didn't see
your agree necessarily with that
analysis I'm gonna change my CNN report
right now I just want to make sure you
know seeing you know what wasn't
so I appreciate it so how much are you
googling your name and reading the
reports that are starting to come out no
smart man I'll see the thing that I see
on my timeline just scrolling down
Twitter what people may tag me in and I
kind of have no choice but to see it but
I mean I don't go out of my way to see
any TV reports or anything like that
coming up in the day only thing I care
about is what the gene but what the
coaches are going to say and who's going
to select me and I mean I'd entered a
it's only 32 genes I want to make a
decision so I mean I'm not too worried
about what everybody else has to say
about my game or anything like that
so I mean I'm just focused on what I can
control and whoever choose to draft me
or pick me is what it's going to be this
is regarded as one of the best wide
receiver classes we've seen in some time
and like you said you trailed a lot of
good ones in your conference over the
years who was the best wide receiver
that you faced during your college
career or even this season and so it's
kind of a lot of different type of
receivers laughter like the viscous or
no he's always had more he's the best
playmaker I've ever guarded I would say
own against Pitman I would say he's one
of the better ball trackers one of the
better hands I've guarded I their
audience he was one of the most
productive receivers I went against an
even Dante that is my freshman year I
thought he's one of the better runners I
went against my whole career so I mean
it was it's a lot of different guys that
I would say bring different things to
the table that can pose challenges and
really made me have to work now you
mentioned Michael Pittman junior from
USC he had the best game of his career
I get Utah what was your guys plan going
into that game and what didn't work to
stop him that's we honestly didn't
really have a game plan we knew that
they had
see for threats everywhere so I mean it
was just just about trying to maintain
just do our job I'm going against I love
on me it was just trying to eliminate
him as best I can and then when Pittman
got hot I mean it wasn't necessarily
anything that not to take away from him
but we just weren't disciplining our
courage as one I think it was a long
time we were undercover three we didn't
really play that too well as we weren't
on top of his on top of him in that
cover three another long one we got they
got some already B's got split on the
double team so I mean it just wasn't it
just wasn't our cleaners technical game
that we played I gave and he made us pay
for it at the end of the day so what
about looking forward to the NFL are
there any receivers that you're looking
forward to trying to lock up on and kind
of test your game against in the NFL
that's a big boy everything every team
wants have that one or two guys that can
really go able to match up every game
against the best and being able to
showcase what I can do on defense as
well and just try to maintain and take
those guys out as much as possible
jaylen has a podcast we've decided that
you were the best player from that Utah
defense this year especially in the
giraffe so we got to ask you who is the
second-best player from your defense in
this draft play most impactful most
impactful we're gonna tag him on Twitter
in this two-man so like don't don't piss
off Bradley and I for him yeah
I'll have it - really I'm stuck between
I'm stuck between three two or three
players oh well you guys are gonna have
eight players on defense drafted that's
other people need to know so it's not
like we're asking you to pick between
two guys do that's fine yes that's fine
Bradley and Julia how big was Julian's
injury for you guys
he's a heck of a player but it seems
like not the defense was ever bad but it
seems like you guys fell off a little
bit definitely and the organ game it
just was more so of missing piece of our
puzzle that we couldn't feel but I
wouldn't even say more so it kinda
messed up the Mojo just because the
whole year we were so used to being one
tight-knit group so when one league kind
of fell off they're just like okay how
are we gonna replace this and this is
all we've had all year and we just want
to use to having somebody else coming
out move very very thin at the safety
position so having them go on the
championship game with just okay well I
mean next man up but I'm next men didn't
really have too much experience so it's
really about trying to do the best that
we can with what we have playing ball
games were there to see how it was with
a full game without him off but I mean
it was just just wanna be the best we
can with what we have are you still
keeping in contact with a lot of guys
you play with it Utah you're all kind of
an uncharted waters here we've never
gone through a draft presa process like
this so you keep it in contact with guys
like Julian I mean I would probably say
I talked to the throw birdies the most
but I mean we we chop it up here and
there with the weather through social
media or wherever
but I mean we're kind of just letting
try to enjoy it really but I mean we all
have all these phone calls and stuff
going on I mean it's not like because we
have much time too much thought to
really think and call each other and
really talk too much but I mean when we
do talk it's nice being able to catch up
and talking about which things we talk
to and just enjoy being able to enjoy it
all together last one from me how many
teams have you talked to is your week
just booked with FaceTime calls over and
over again since the combine that's a
good number and what the last question
will let you get out of here man doing
this over the years you find out players
have an instinct like a hunch for where
they're gonna get drafted a lot of times
they're right if you had to guess right
now which team is going to draft you I
am for sure not like you know where you
want to go yeah it doesn't have to be
like hey I'm only playing for this team
don't want you to go Eli Manning on this
thing but if you just had a hunch a good
feeling about a team okay you're a Cali
guy right that'd be great
well they're not they're Vegas now but
close enough you're definitely a mike
Mayock Connie it makes a lot of odds
there with what they are trying to build
their what they need at corner I think
that's a good hunch I think you're
probably right I think so too
I'm gonna change my mock drafts all
right Jalen thank you so much for your
time man good luck we have been talking
to you
good luck three having the shoulder good
luck working out with a girlfriend
that's that's the test on a relationship
man so so good for you doing that but
stay safe out there and good luck
when the Raiders pick you will be room
for you man
you